and now our next host Alan King he's
been amazing what one man can do with a
roll of rental wrap good evening welcome
to Monday bloody Monday tonight is a
night filled with excitement and
surprise joy for some and disappointment
for others it's an evening filled with
curiosity and suspense from sure and
everyone's mind right now there's one
question what is Alan king doing here
now considering the fact that in 14
years I've only made two pictures I can
understand why I've been given this
great honor 14 years ago in the Helen
Morgan story I played a young gangster
with my old nose last year and the
Anacin tapes I played an old gangster
with my new nose I may have it removed
completely actually the reason I had it
fix is because I was turned down for
role in a picture you producers will
know that they said I look too Jewish it
was for the part of Tevye in Fiddler on
the Roof
but I must confess I feel a little like
an outsider here tonight for first I'm
not a resident of this great city of Los
Angeles I still make my home in New York
but we do share something in common we
both have mayor's who live out of town
mine because of fear and yours because
of boredom
you know my friends are always asking me
Alan how could you live in New York move
out to California everybody's so relaxed
the reason you're so relaxed is because
you've got so many massage parlors out
here
everyone tells me that Hollywood is the
cultural center of the world
it's got movies television theater
forgive me but personally I still prefer
the Broadway theater not that the plays
out here are bad but somehow I don't
enjoy seeing the great white hope with
Eddie Bracken as an outsider to me the
most fascinating thing about the motion
picture industry is the concept behind
the Academy Awards this event is so
dramatic and mind-boggling that it's
being watched on television five out of
every six homes in America over a
hundred million people are viewing this
program at this very moment you realize
what that means tonight and all the
motion picture theaters an American
combined there are 17 people watching
movies that's not bad enough six of them
rushes two guys are waiting for the next
Ali Fraser fight and Jerry Lewis
when it I'll give you all the time you
need when it comes to making motion
pictures you people are the best in the
world and I mean that technically
there's no end of the miracles you
accomplish you scale mountains with your
cameras descend to the bottoms of oceans
journey into disease-infested jungles
risking your lives two audiences will be
entertained but what do you really know
about danger when was the last time you
sat in the balcony of the lowest Pitkin
in Brooklyn now that's danger I'm trying
to get crime back into the street so
they leave me alone in the movies
in my neighborhood the godfathers is
considered a training film what do you
know about going to the movies you go to
private screenings when was the last
time you stood in line let me tell you
what it's like your arrival to theater
at 5:30 to be on time for a 6 o'clock
show and you find a line that starts at
the box office goes all the way around
the block through a Walgreens drugstore
into a Greek delicatessen through a
Polish tattoo parlor where you can watch
a guy misspell the word mum
but it's worth it where else but in New
York and you see in one block
slaughterhouse five million mustards
desperate characters and Dirty Harry all
standing in line next to you you know
what a thrill it is to stand in a Cove
or four hours shivering hungry and wet
hearing people coming out of the theater
saying don't go in it's not white it the
first thing you do when you get in is
you buy a piece of candy now I know you
people are always complaining about the
rising cost of production when was the
last time you bought a piece of candy at
the movies when I was a kid you bought a
Baby Ruth for a nickel today they only
have one size family a 50-pound box of
chocolate with doilies it looks like a
candy gram you'd send Mama Cass while my
favorite is the hot dog you haven't
lived until you've eaten a hot dog that
was cooked in the lobby of the criterion
theatre one bite and your entire life
flashes before your eyes
but
but it's never hot they folded a toaster
napkin it comes in you know
believe me being a movie goer isn't easy
but enough of my problems we're here
tonight to discuss your problems the
awards and I don't want to say that I
personally have any favorites so what if
Fiddler on the Roof doesn't win the
worst thing happens the Academy gets a
nasty letter from the anti-defamation
league that's nothing compared to what's
going to happen next year if the
Godfather doesn't win
you know it's only natural that
everybody would be making jokes about
the Godfather but if I may take this
liberty I think that paramount is to be
congratulated last year for love story
and this year for The Godfather and you
know they did it the hard way
without ever mentioning the word mafia
or Cosa Nostra in other words being The
Godfather is never having to say you're
Sicilian and after a joke starting
tomorrow
my wife will warm up the car
now on with the awards to present the
best achievement and live-action and
animated short subjects the lady who
gave so compelling her performance in
the last picture show Cloris Leachman
and the gentleman who gave the gentleman
who gave an equally compelling
performance in shaft Richard Roundtree
okay well I'm new in pictures and the
award we're giving sounded very
technical to me but I found out it's
really the seed from which all movies
grew because that's precisely what the
first films were live-action short
subjects with a bow to Mack Sennett Mary
Pickford Lillian Gish and above all
yes above all a very deep bow to mr.
Charles Spencer Chaplin do I dare call
him Charlie why not the whole world does
for the best achievement in live-action
short subjects the nominations are good
morning produced by Danny Evans and Ken
Greenwald the rehearsal produced by
Steven Verona sentinels of silence
produced by Manuel
Arango and Robert Amram and the winner
is sentinels of silence
Manuela Rondo and Robert Conrad
thank you very much
IRA gravity to the old members ed
Academy thank you
the best achievement in an animated
short subjects the nominations are the
crunch bird
Ted P top producer evolution Michael
Mills producer The Selfish Giant penis
sander and Mauritius Tech and the winner
is the crunch bird
Ted Peeta
Oh crunch bird my Oscar
oh I'd like to thank my partners
Joe Petrovich Len Maxwell Carl Fischer
Doris Petrovich Frank Walt cancer you
know this picture is only 2 minutes and
24 seconds and I've got 9 minutes worth
of credits but I really would like to
thank all the members of the Academy for
having so honored us thank you